Speaker 1: So we've already looked at the
current factions of the Republican Party,
the pro and the anti Trump Republicans,
the pro Trump Republicans are now
split into sort of the CU wing, which are
people that support people like Marjorie
Taylor Green and Matt Gates. And then you've
got the sort of pro Trump but anti CU wing of
the modern Republican Party. These are people that
generally like Trump, but they don't like all of
these problematic hangers on that have surfaced.
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham seems to think
that none of these factions really matter insofar
as the Republican Party absolutely needs. Donald
Trump is dependent on Donald Trump's involvement
in their party, and they simply cannot move
forward as a viable political party without Donald
Trump, which is a very strong statement to make.
But there is a reason we call Lindsey
Graham flimsy Lindsey. And comparing his
latest statements over the weekend with those
in the past will tell us a lot about that. Now,
the first question is whether Lindsey Graham is
in some sense correct in what he is now saying,
whether or not he believes it. Right. Is he simply
saying this because he's in Trump's good graces
and Trump's involvement in Republican politics
is good for Lindsey? There are all sorts of
reasons he might be saying this. He may
mean that. He may not. But let's look at
what Lindsey Graham had to say over the weekend.
Speaker 2: Just say to my Republican colleagues,
can we move forward without President Trump?
The answer is no. I've always liked Liz Cheney,
but she's made a determination that the Republican
Party can't can't grow with President Trump.
I've determined we can't grow without him.
All of these people like Herschel Walker and
all the people you just named are attracted to
the Trump Republican Party, economic populism,
America first agenda. If you don't get that
as a Republican, you're making the biggest
mistake in the history of the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: This is actually really interesting
because Lindsey is not wrong,
that people like Herschel Walker
and a ton of those that we saw being interviewed
or we're going to see being interviewed at this
event in Florida over the weekend saying, listen,
I saw it on TV. Trump won all of this stuff.
It is 100 percent true that a lot of these people
never paid attention to American politics before
Donald Trump. It is true that it was Trump's
populist rhetoric and his America first agenda
that attracted them to Donald Trump. The practical
issue, though, is what effect that actually had,
because Trump's populist rhetoric never
materialized into policy. All the stuff Trump ran
on either didn't happen or it was perverted into
some crony handout like PCP is an example. Trump's
America first agenda ended up alienating much of
the Western world who were our long term allies.
And case in point, Republican Trump ism led to
Republicans losing the House of Representatives
in twenty eighteen, losing the Senate in 2020,
losing the White House in twenty twenty. Now,
the entire analysis is predicated on Lindsay is
now being sincere. I don't know if he is, because
remember that on the evening of January 6th,
in the midst of the Trump riots, Lindsey Graham
seemed to say on the floor of the Senate, this is
too much about the direction of Trump ism, is what
led people to riot on January 6th, and he can't
be a part of it. Remember when Lindsey said this?
Speaker 4: Trump and I, we've had a hell of
a journey. I hate it this way. Oh, my God,
I hate it. From my point of view, he's
been a consequential president. But the day
first thing you'll see. All I can say
is count me out. Enough is enough.
I've tried to be helpful, but when this Wisconsin
Supreme Court ruled four to three that they didn't
violate the supreme the Constitution of Wisconsin,
I agree with the three, but I accept the four.
If Al Gore can accept five, four, he's not
president. I can accept Wisconsin four to three.
Pennsylvania, it went to the Second Circuit, so
much for all the judges being in Trump's pocket.
They said, no, you're wrong, I accept the
Pennsylvania 2nd Circuit that Trump's lawsuit
wasn't wasn't right. Georgia, they said the
secretary of state took the law in his own hands.
He changed the election laws unlawfully. A federal
judge said, no, I accept the federal judge,
even though I don't agree with it, fraud. They
say they're sixty six thousand people in Georgia
under 18 voted. How many people believe
that? I asked. Give me ten and had one.
They said eight thousand felons in prison
in Arizona voted, give me 10 had got what?
That say there's there's problems
in every election. I don't buy this,
enough's enough, we've got to end it.
Speaker 1: So the question, of course,
is which Lindsey Graham is the sincere one
and if he's posturing and trying to get back
in trumps good graces now that it seems Trump does
want to stay involved in Republican Party politics
at least through 2022, maybe depending on how
that goes into 2024. If Lindsey is just saying
what he thinks Trump wants to hear, is it even
worth it for the Republican Party to listen to
Lindsey Graham? Trump may be great for Lindsey.
So Lindsey can have the president on speed dial,
get rides on the presidential helicopter and on
Air Force One, all of that stuff. But just because
it's good and fun and exciting for Lindsey Graham
to be friends with the president doesn't mean it's
actually good for the Republican Party. And again,
if you want another example of why they call this
guy flimsy, Lindsey just waving in the wind, going
with whatever direction it's blowing politically.
This is the same Lindsey Graham early in the 2016
primary. Denouncing Donald Trump and accurately
so remember this. What is your
Speaker 4: reaction to hearing
what Donald Trump says
Speaker 2: and disgusted?
I want to talk to the Trump supporters for a
minute. I don't know who you are and I don't know
why you like this guy. I think what you like about
him, he appears to be strong when the rest of us
are weak. He's a very successful businessman.
He's going to make everything great. He's going
to take all the problems of the world and put
them in a box and make your life better. That's
what he is selling. Here's what you're buying.
He's a race baiting, xenophobic, religious bigot.
He doesn't represent my party. He doesn't
represent the values that the men and women
who wear the uniform are fighting for.
Speaker 1: So the point is, I don't trust
Lindsey Graham as far as I can throw him. But
it doesn't matter. Since I'm not trying to help
the Republican Party, I don't need to figure
out whether I need to be listening to Lindsey
Graham or not. For me, it's just a question
of will the Republican Party fall for this?
The Republican Party, on the other hand, does have
to figure out their framework and their structure
heading into 2022. And that race starts in six
months. Understand that there's not an unlimited
amount of time for the Republican Party to
decide which direction are we going to go
and are we going the anti Trump side, which
is one side? Are we going pro trump anti que?
Or are we going full in queue, Marjorie
Taylor, Green Mat Gates, these types of people,
it's down to about six months
for them to figure it out.